Le code ?
Quel code ?
Le code d'entrée
J'en sais rien moi, j'habite pas là
De quoi, mais tu l'as pas pris ? mais tu te fous de ...
Mais non, mais t'es con ou quoi ?
"...Pardon..."
Permettez ?
Oui
Bonne soirée
Regarde ce que j'ai trouvé
J'ai trouvé ça
N-non non non
Chuchotements
On ne bouge plus !
Mains en l'air !
Et toi, tu poses Michel Sardou
C'est ton mec, lui ?
Ouais, et alors. Et alors quoi ?
Ta gueule
Ouais
À plat ventre, tout de suite !
Cheminée ...
Quoi ?
On monte par la cheminée, on arrive sur le toit et on descend par la gouttière
Mais y'a pas de cheminée
Et y'a pas de cheminée ...
Merde
Du coup, pour sortir par la cheminée, ... C'est plus compliqué
Bon, écoutez, ça commence à devenir insultant de m'ignorer de la sorte.
Alors, s'il vous plait : à plat ventre, tout de suite.
Ok, ok
Alors non, je suis désolée, je vais pas m'alonger
Parce que ...
Parce que je suis enceinte
Quoi ?
Oh
Ah, je suis enceinte
T'avais pas remarqué ?
De quoi ? Et tu m'annonces ça devant monsieur, comme ça, là, tout de suite ...
Il est peut-être même pas de moi, on sait pas
Quoi, nan mais attends, ça me déçois vachement ce que tu viens de dire là.
Bon
Pardon d'y revenir mais je ne  vois pas le bordel de rapport avec le cambriolage de ma maison.
T'as une arme braquée sur moi alors que je suis enceinte !
Si tu tires, c'est deux en un
Je vais être Papa
Je peux pas, ça va pas, ça va pas du tout là, ça va pas, c'est une crise d'angoisse c'est ça les crises d'angoisse.
Ouais, ouais, bah c'est peut-être aussi parce que tu as l'arme de l'autre braquée sur toi.
Alors l'autre, il faudra pas trop lui manquer de respect
Parce que je peux vous flinguer
Si vous n'avez pas compris l''urgence du truc
Non, mais je veux dire normal quoi
Légitime défense
Il va falloir lui trouver un prénom et tout
Légitime défense ?
Mais on t'a jamais menacé nous, que je sache.
Et on l'a fait où, où est-ce .. Le jour où on l'a fait, c'était quand ?
Laser Quest
Ouais
Derrière le petit muret là
Dites, les deux cons
Pardon de recentrer un peu le débat
Mais si, si c'est de la légitime défense.
Mets-toi devant moi
Quoi ?
Bouclier !
Bouclier de femme enceinte !
Bon allez, vous me faites chier.
Cassez-vous maintenant.
Vas-y, vas-y, ...
Non, vraiment tu reposes Michel !
C'est pour le petit, pour lui chanter des berceuses le soir
Bon ok...
T'es un mec bien, vraiment.
Désolé hein ?
Au revoir.
Je sais pas si je suis prêt, mais ...
un bébé ça fait caca, ça vomit et parfois les deux,
et moi, je suis émétophobe.
Mais je suis pas du tout enceinte patate !
C'était du bluff.
Ah bon ?
Ah ouais, ouais ok
Tu veux aller au Laser Quest ?
Ah, bah c'est trop tard, là. Là, c'est fermé.
Pour niquer
Ouais...
Allez viens.
Bon allez, prends leurs sacs.
Et puis, prends le tableau.
Il doit valoir de la tune aussi.
Pas mal, le coup de la femme enceinte.
Je vais l'essayer la prochaine fois.
Bah non.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que t'es trop ...
T'as pas le ..
Tais-toi.
Bah parce que t'es trop vieille oui quoi,c'est ça.
Allez, on se casse. Avant que le proprio arrive.